the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
last class we introduced thin-film
technologies we describe some of their
generic advantages and disadvantages I
showed that particular book that's going
around in the back there the handbook
affordable take science and engineering
that describes several the technologies
that we're discussing today and last
class last class we covered general thin
films and cad-tel
cadmium telluride today we're going to
be talking about amorphous silicon
copper indium gallium diselenide and the
last material system which is actually
more of a stack or a composite of
several then we'll enter a debate which
would be kind of fun so amorphous
silicon we talked about crystalline
silicon crystalline silicon is the
crystalline form of the element known as
silicon comprising a diamond cubic
crystal structure amorphous silicon on
the other hand is a very broad term
caching a range of materials that lack
long-range order let me be a little bit
more specific typically there is some
semblance of short-range order in these
materials one can describe the
composition of amorphous silicon using
say for example a radial distribution
function the average distance from one
atom to the next and you have these
distribution functions describing the
material it gets a little bit more
tricky when you try to define it on a
more detailed level with average number
of nearest neighbors the local
configuration the number of stretched
bonds locally and the reality is that
with any amorphous material you can
deposit a range of materials it isn't
just one specific amorphous silicon
material that you get every time
depending on your deposition conditions
depending on the pressure and the
temperature and the power during during
the PC VD the plasma enhanced chemical
vapour deposition you obtain a range of
amorphous silicon materials and that
range or within that range you can find
that the mobility of charge carriers can
vary by several factors the mobility I
believe in a more facility can range
easily between 0.0 0.1 centimeter square
per volt second so that's two orders of
magnitude easily and I have heard of
amorphous silicon materials that have
gone as low as 10 to the minus 4
centimeter square per volt second and as
high
as approaching one so we have a range of
material qualities as a result and also
a range of performance likewise there's
a range of stress in the film depending
on how you deposit your morpha silicon
so delamination is of concern as well
depending on how you deposit it and the
challenge is from the material level is
getting a consistent quality material
high quality material every single
deposition and overcoming certain
degradation modes that are present in a
more facility not present in other
material systems certainly not present
in crystalline silicon for example the
stapler on ski defect that's still up
for some debate as to what precisely is
the the atomic in nature of that defect
but it is known that when one exposes
amorphous silicon to sunlight that the
performance will degrade with a
relatively quick time constants over the
period of minutes and hours and finally
stabilized so when you report the cell
performance of an amorphous silicon cell
it's always very important to emphasize
that this is light degraded or light
stabilized efficiency as opposed to the
efficiency you get when you take it
straight out of the deposition chamber
and it hasn't been exposed to high
amounts of sunlight yet in general
amorphous silicon has low hole mobility
again the precise root cause on an
atomic scale for the low hole mobility
is still up for some debate there's a
professor here at MIT
Jeff Grossman who has performed a
combination of molecular dynamics and
and density functional theory to obtain
amorphous silicon samples in DFT and
through those samples he is he was able
to determine he and his colleagues were
able to determine that the low mobility
might be caused by stretched bonds
certain types of stretched bonds within
the amorphous silicon there are other
hypotheses out there as well in the
literature finally just getting a
uniform film deposition at high speed
that's really a key a high speed uniform
deposition of this layer has proved
challenging and commercial production so
far so all of this has combined so that
amorphous silicon has
received a lot of attention but hasn't
yet in a massive way been economically
successful this is a cross-section SEM
of an amorphous silicon device showing
the TCO the transparent conducting oxide
on the top the TCO is deposited onto the
glass which appears at the very top
underneath the scale bar the amorphous
silicon layer right here in the middle
is shown it is in a key i-n structure so
we've learned about PN junctions the AI
layer in between is an intrinsic layer
meaning lightly doped and this will see
the been diagram on the next slide the
silver contact on the back here
extracting the charge from the backside
so this is an example of the amorphous
silicon technology again another
cross-section just for your reference
showing the stack there okay the pin2
vais architecture the right here we can
see the ki+ layer or the P layer the N
layer and then the I here in the middle
of the lightly doped intrinsic layer
note the band structure or the band
diagram how its how its arranged and
interestingly the layer thicknesses here
are in the order of 300 nanometers for
the entire stack it's rather thin
typically under a micron in thickness
the reason is very thin is because
amorphous silicon absorbs light much
much better than crystalline silicon for
those who have a solid-state physics
background and want to know the root
cause of that I'll explain briefly for
those who don't have the background and
can't follow don't worry plant a flag
will come right back to it so in
crystalline silicon we have crystal
symmetry and hence we have momentum
conservation rules when we excite charge
carriers
hence the indirect band gap nature of
crystalline silicon when we amorphize
our material we no longer have that
crystal symmetry we no longer have
momentum conservation we can excite
directly from your valence band into
your conduction band so that in a very
quick hand wavy way is why a Morpha
silicon tends to behave like a direct
bandgap semiconductor absorbing light
extremely well with a very high optical
absorption coefficient hence instead of
a hundred microns we can get away with
300 nanometers of thickness
all right back to our flag we see here
the PN structure everybody should be
able to follow along and understand that
if light excites a charge carrier here
in the middle the electrons will be
swept to the right the holes to the left
and we'll have charge separation
occurring sometimes we can have a stack
of materials like sone here with varying
band gaps by for example blending
germanium into the amorphous silicon
this can modify the band gap of the
material and we can wind up with a stack
of layers or we could simply use two
layers of the same material we wouldn't
necessarily be able to absorb more
efficiently across the solar spectrum
but we would be able to be increased the
voltage output of the device so there's
a variety of different amorphous silicon
shall we say designs out there in the
market here are here's one example of
the triple stack we have a morphus
silicon here at the top with a large
band gap the band gap is somewhere in
the range of one point 70 B yep question
yeah yeah so in this particular case I
believe this is a dual terminal device
which would be rather tricky to perform
an operation well you have to imagine
this is right here with with very small
perturbation if you imagine it being
biased in sunlight then you can easily
see how a larger voltage would result
right here you can you can imagine a two
terminal device where you extract charge
from here and here or perhaps a four
terminal device which is less common
because it requires a more metal
contacts but I would contact the device
here here again here and here so you'd
have the two devices contacted if you
have a two terminal device one can
typically think about it as adding the
voltages together then it would be the
current would be limited by the worst
performer of those two and that's why
you have this thinner than that one over
here because we know that the light
tends to be absorbed preferentially near
the front surface we're absorbing an
equivalent number of photons in this
thickness and in that thickness so the
currents tend to be matched so that's
why I would I would guess given the
geometry the fact that we have silver on
the back and TCO on the front and no
explicit contacts here in the middle
that this is a two terminal device as
opposed to a four this stack right here
is representative of what is
commercialized by uni solar company in
Michigan where we have an amorphous
silicon layer on the top wide bandgap
semiconductor somewhere in the range of
1.7 to 1.9 TV depending on the
deposition conditions again I mentioned
that amorphous silicon is really a range
of materials there is no one in more
facility and it's depending on the the
the density of atoms inside of the
amorphous structure and their local
configuration you can vary the
properties quite a bit so the bandgap
can vary but typically it's in the range
of 1.7 to 1.9 TV blending in germanium
germanium being a bigger atom tends to
reduce the band gap of the material and
you have successively higher
concentrations moving toward the back so
the band gap shrinks from front to back
and you can wind up with a stack like
this and this is an example here of a
three cell stack where you have the
combined quantum efficiency and the
individual quantum efficiencies of each
of the sub cells showing you how you can
really fill up the entire solar spectrum
using a combination of these materials
unfortunately despite all these efforts
the material is still affected by what's
called the state baranski effect in
honor of the people who initially
determined it what the the stapler
Otsuki effects typically manifests
itself as a degradation of material
performance as a function of time it's
also known that as the the layer
thickness increases the predominance of
this effect also increases and this
impact also increases so it manifests
itself as a reduction of the fill factor
reduction of performance and we see the
trade-offs during device design of
amorphous silicon so that's would say
the the the essence of amorphous silicon
is that it's a very promising material
has a wide degree of tunability but the
low hole mobility limits its performance
to somewhere around 10 percent for just
a single amorphous silicon layer and in
the low teens for the stacks of multiple
materials one on top of another
this right here is showing an
interesting effect when you begin
heating up your substrate when you're
depositing amorphous silicon you have
amorphous material if you heat up your
substrate too too high of a temperature
during the deposition process and this
is also impacted by the concentration of
silane gas to hydrogen ratio during the
deposition process one can obtain a
phase transition from amorphous material
into what's called micro crystalline
material that's shown at the very top
asi stands for amorphous silicon mu SI
for micro crystalline silicon micro
crystalline silicon is right at the face
transition between an amorphous silicon
and a crystalline variant
polycrystalline variant of silicon and
in some cases can actually contain a
mixture of both amorphous and
crystalline regions and so it's very
tricky to nail the deposition conditions
just right somebody along the way
figured out whoa wait a second we can
actually use this micro crystalline
silicon to our advantage and stack a
layer of micro crystalline silicon on
the bottom put a layer of amorphous
silicon on the top and that was called
micro morph
technology as a result and there are
companies that have commercialized
micromorph excuse me sneeze right there
so the micro morph technology
commercialized by Oerlikon and
previously by a company in the United
States called Applied Materials and
we'll get to that in a couple of slides
as well this right here is a brief slide
just addressing the issue of how growth
conditions can impact material quality
there are a number of growth growth
parameters shall we say that impact
whether you obtain an amorphous material
with high mobility with low mobility a
micro crystalline material nano
crystalline material and so forth and if
you're interested in more details
these NRL reports from the late 1990s
and early 2000s mid 2000s are really a
treasure trove of information if you
really want to get up to speed quickly
on how to grow high quality amorphous
silicon layers okay so these are record
amorphous silicon cell efficiencies this
I believe was from the Martin green
tables that come out each half-year in
progress in photovoltaics so he and his
colleagues produce an article every half
of a year in progress in photovoltaics
describing the record efficiencies of
lab sized cells maybe a centimeter
squared all the way up to full sized
modules so we have here our Morpheus
silicon and the blended amorphous
silicon germanium or a ciggy for short
people sometimes call silicon germanium
ciggy so we have a variety of different
types shown here and the areas of the
devices shown here I would caution over
interpretation of the very small area
devices if you have 2.25 centimeters you
had a very small linear dimension along
the side of the cell and you can wind up
being impacted by edge effects there's
also sometimes these this is the active
area of a much larger device where
they've shrunken down the aperture but
depending on the texturization of the
surface you still get light trapping and
and essentially a larger active area
than what is actually being shaded off
so
I would caution you against over
interpreting these very small area
measurements one centimeter squared
larger you're typically in a regime
where where the results are more
believable the JSC is shown here
VOCs shown here note in certain cases
the the vo see you would expect from
amorphous silicon if it's a bandgap of
1.7 TV you would expect a VOCs somewhere
in the range of maybe one point four
volts and and sometimes you get much
lower than that likewise the
short-circuit current is is rather low
say compared to a crystalline silicon
device because of that higher bandgap
the inability to capture some of those
lower energy photons and so the record
single amorphous silicon device
performance somewhere in the you know
buttressing up against ten percent not
quite and then if you combine different
layers into a stack for example here you
can move into the low teens for your
performance flag that these numbers here
we're going to get back to this and use
that to understand why some of the
technologies didn't make it to
commercialization this represents the
largest scale attempt to commercialize
amorphous silicon technology this was a
turnkey line let's start from over here
this is a human being seated at a
computer to humans this pod right here
this machine represents one of these
little components right here that fits
into a much larger assembly line this is
the P CVD reactor actually there were I
believe there were seven of them
attached to each of these little pods
right here so the the plasmid has
chemical vapour deposition reactors were
depositing micro micro crystalline
silicon and amorphous silicon onto
sheets of glass that were as large as
you could possibly transport does
anybody just happen to know the number
off the top of their head what is the
largest sheet of glass that you can
physically transport saying in
commercial form such that you could buy
it in bulk without custom design of the
Pilkington full glass process
it's about yeah yeah definitely says
that's a good place to start it's
actually dictated by what can fit on
some of the trucks that transport the
glass back and forth we've ever seen the
glass transport trucks with the the
sides where they put the panes of glass
in and they're the chasis of the truck
like so and the glass along the edge
it's around three by three point three
meters and so these deposition systems
could incorporate huge sheets of glass
and it would leave it up to the customer
whether they wanted to quarter them and
make reasonable size modules or whether
they want the full-size module and have
to use cranes to install them which
would reduce the labor content of
installation but would shift the burden
onto the automation so you see the the
paints of glass coming along pre
cleaning and eventually insertion to
these devices why so many of those
devices why so many PC VD reactors like
little piglets around a pod here they
were each of these reactors would have
say a cycle time somewhere in the order
of a few tens of minutes so my estimate
would be somewhere between twenty and
thirty minutes maybe up to forty because
the micro crystalline silicon layer just
sucked all took so long to deposit but
without that micro crystalline layer it
was difficult to reach ten percent
efficiency with jesse amorphous silicon
layer the efficiencies were in the range
of 6 to 7 percent and if you start doing
calculations for a six or a seven
percent module you realize very quickly
that the cost of the glass and the
encapsulants and everything else adds up
because your device is so low in
efficiency that you need more in capsule
more glass more labor more installation
to produce a panel to produce the same
amount of power and as a result the
system cost was very high
this technology couldn't compete once
the Chinese production started really
ramping up in the market and decreasing
the cost of traditional crystal and
silicon modules and the the Sun fab
project which was applied materials
named for this this amorphous silicon
line or micromorph line in reality was
shut down recently relatively recently
about a year ago when it was realized
that this was no longer commercially
viable in the faces of the low-cost
competition from crystalline silicon all
that could change very quickly if
somehow one of you were to develop a way
to say double the record efficiency
number so if someone were to figure out
why exactly hole mobility is so low in
pairing transport inside of these
materials in principle one could then
envision rolling it out into the Sun fab
line there's already a turnkey
production equipment that's been built
by Applied Materials ready to go and
you're off and running so that's an
opportunity out there this lists some of
the commercialization attempts and the
bottom line in the end of the day was
that six percent modules were too
inefficient to be profitable unless you
reach scales of say gigawatts and
believe it or not there was one company
out there called opti solar the business
plan was literally to scale up to a
gigawatt faster than everybody else and
even though it was lower performance the
sheer size and scale of the
manufacturing facility would reduce the
cost of the amorphous silicon relative
to crystalline silicon competition
unfortunately opti solar didn't make it
either so the companies that are left
today
producing amorphous silicon include
Oerlikon this is a Swiss company that
produces turnkey equipment and uni solar
which is selling the actual modules of
amorphous silicon they have a nice roll
to roll deposition process on these
stainless steel foils very nice Factory
believe it was toured by several for
members of our current administration
and they're they're still going yeah
what is it what is he um I usually think
based on the color that this already has
amorphous silicon deposited onto it but
it could be at some intermediate phase I
I don't know for that specific role but
in principle yes at the end of their
manufacturing line they'll have a full
stack the the triple amorphous silicon
and the two layers of ciggy beneath it
so what they incorporate there their
flexible material into typically one of
their products is roof shingle that
looks very similar to a standard asphalt
based roof shingle and it is very nice
building integrated technology I happen
to see one back in when I was a graduate
student and was inspired by the building
integrated potential there mm-hmm
so there are attempts to integrate
amorphous silicon into regular
crystalline silicon technology as well
turns out amorphous silicon passivates
the surfaces very nicely and you can
create what's called a hit cell
structure which is a heterojunction with
a thin intrinsic layer using a silicon
substrate typically what's used is a an
n-type base and then the amorphous
silicon layers are deposited on either
side and that device is currently being
commercialized by a company called sanyo
in japan the patents for the base hit
cell structure expire very soon if they
haven't expired already and so there are
there is a fair amount of interest
several companies out there right now
attempting to reproduce this process but
it is fairly tricky and again a lot of
it boils down to managing the interfaces
making sure that the interface between
the silicon the crystalline silicon and
the amorphous silicon are of high
quality
so we have our hit cell structure here
let me hop over to the last thin film
material so we have adequate time for
our debates the copper indium gallium
diselenide or cigs for short this is a
quaternary phase sometimes comprised of
even five elements but let's let's show
this is the choco pyrite structure right
here with copper shown in black
indium or gallium shown in gray
typically there's some blend between the
two and the chalcogen the selenium or
sulphur shown in the white right here
typically selenium so we have here an
example the crystal structure as I
understand the situation this crystal
structure came into being because copper
sulfide demonstrated potential as a
photovoltaic material early on seeing
the late 1970s early 1980s there were
attempts to grow high-performance copper
sulfide cells they failed because copper
electro migrated in the presence of an
electric field copper a very small ion
far to the right on the 3d series of
elements so if you look at the
transition metals copper is on the far
right meaning you're adding more and
more and more protons to the nucleus as
you go from left to right and you're
pulling the outer shell in so if you
look at atomic radius going from left to
right in the periodic table you'll see
that the atoms tend to shrink so copper
being on the far right-hand side of the
3d elemental series has a smaller atomic
radius compared to say iron or manganese
or titanium and as a result it could
move fairly easily throughout the
lattice if it is present in a charged
state if you have say copper plus and a
large electric field distributed across
the thin film solar cell device so
copper sulphide devices ended up
degrading quickly over time and it was
realized that some heavier elements
needed to be included to stabilize the
crystal structure so in the lab the
reason why is cigs this particular
material right here is so interesting is
because in the laboratory efficiencies
on the order of 20 percent have been
achieved for large area you'll have to
correct this number right here you can
increase that to 15% plus 15.7% in fact
over a large area devices that's a very
recent result coming out of Mia Soleil
company in California there are dozens
of startup companies focused on SIG's
development and it is a very challenging
problem to get the stoichiometry right
and to passivate the defects inside of
the structure including surfaces where
many companies fail or fall short is
getting the story on
we just write over a large area it's as
simple as a manufacturing challenge the
idealized structure of these thin film
devices you have your SIG's layer right
here in the middle in this case it's
shown as CIS or sis but you can add
gallium as well typically gallium is
blended in Mali molybdenum back contact
on the glass the glass in this case is
just the support for the structure
molybdenum here would be non transparent
to be opaque layer the copper or the
cadmium sulphide on the front side here
forms a very nice interface with the
SIG's layer underneath preventing any
interface damage or any segregation say
of gallium to the surface here and in
the zinc oxide layer on the top which
serves as the buffer window layer
depending is then deposited on the
cadmium sulfide layer and eventually
charges is brought away this right here
is another three-dimensional rendition
to the same what is unique about each of
those dozens of startup companies is the
process in which they deposit the cigs
layer typically so you have companies
like neo-soul a that are invested in
sputtering of cigs
you have companies like nanosolar that
are invested in Inc based printing of
cigs so they print an ink down and then
they Center the ink to form the layer
and like those two there are several
many other companies out there that are
depositing cigs in some way shape or
form
the folks at NRL seem to be more in
favor of a thermal evaporation based
process for cigs
many of the more successful industrial
renditions of cigs right now at least
the ones that are appear most promising
are using other deposition methods so
you'll see a variety out there of
deposition methods for cigs technology
and one of the things to keep track of
as you watch and monitor all of these
startup companies is to bend them by
their their process and and to begin to
discern trends as we start to see some
market leaders evolve in the sector
begin to this discern which technologies
are the most appropriate
perhaps for large-scale deposition of
this material system interfaces are
critical here are some examples of
attempts at mapping out and quite
successful attempts at mapping out the
shall we say the band diagram of a SIG's
based solar cell one thing to keep in
mind is that just like a morphus silicon
represents a broad class of materials
cigs also represents a broad class of
stoichiometry z' meaning the ratio of
indium to gallium the ratio of if you
included at all sulfur to selenium is
critical in determining the properties
of both the bulk and the surfaces
typically at the surfaces you will get
termination by one atom one atomic
species or another one elemental species
or another and that will determine to a
large degree the electronic quality of
that surface so for a long time in
literature you had debating worldviews
of what the band diagram of a cigs
device really looked at like and it
turned out a lot of people were right
they just had varying starting materials
so they were comparing apples to oranges
the the thing that keeps people going
with cigs is that in the laboratory
efficiencies I believe now up to 21%
have been demonstrated so that is really
encouraging
I mean people venture capitals will look
at this and say wow with those high
efficiencies you could really make solar
cheap the amount of again glass and
capsules labor and so forth that you you
have to have per watt-peak is lower
because the cell can perform at a higher
performance but the downside is there's
a gap between a substantial gap between
what is commercially manufacturable
today and that record efficiency device
sometimes the the practical matters of
commercialization are the ones that
impede a technology in beginning to
market and I have some modicum of faith
that cigs will make it but if it fails
to reach mark its true market potential
if it fails to realize it's it's his
dream of becoming a significant fraction
of all solar panels produced it will
most likely be because of these process
engineering issues associated with
depositing over a large area coupled to
the scientific would say gap and
managing interfaces properly so that's
the story of cigs in a nutshell there
are some minor issues shall we say
associated with cadmium there are
attempts to go to an all where we're
right here to an all zinc oxide or maybe
a graded zinc oxide buffer and window
layer here in the front to get rid of
the cab iam will discuss that shortly
and there are yeah I would say that's
that's probably the biggest near-term
challenge without with with the removal
of cadmium you can access more markets
and and secondly cigs does contain
indium which is not in an infinite
supply in Earth's crust it's debatable
how much of an issue that that really is
and we'll get to that in our discussions
as well you know debates six
commercialization several startup
companies and and and I would say a lot
of promising research and development
going on right now the this particular
technology right here shown let's let's
keep this company nameless for now this
company represents some of the
difficulties in ramping up large area
cigs they deposited sometimes over large
areas but would achieve in homogeneous
results and so the ultimate form factor
for the devices was to chop them up into
areas that are not too dissimilar from
an actual crystalline silicon device so
to chop up their layers into individual
discrete cells and then to connect them
solder them together much like a
crystalline silicon device would be put
together inside of a module so the dream
of having this inline thin film process
roll-to-roll
was was reaching an abrupt wall shall we
say in the development process because
of the lack of large-scale uniformity so
you need to chop them up into smaller
units which would add to the cost which
would decrease the module performance as
well because and now you have gaps in
between the cells so it just goes to
show the the difficulty of bringing a
new technology to market and hopefully
they're doing better now
lots of promising news for cigs like
this particular article the rise of cigs
finally question mark there are there
has always been a lot of promise for in
in the in the realm of cigs because of
the high performance and the high
efficiencies reached the big question is
can you accomplish this at large scale
for large area modules that's been the
the big challenge so far
and of course materials availability so
let me pause right here what I'm going
to do we are going to shift gears and
for the next 20 minutes unfortunately
not half an hour over the next 20
minutes we are going to enter debate
mode what we're going to do is divide
the group into this group right here
into your project teams and you'll
cluster together and work together on
this next exercise so for the very
beginning we're going to have the
cadmium telluride debate that will be
debate number one will be discussing the
pros and cons of cad-tel keep in mind
that first solar a gigawatt company
meaning of one of the largest companies
in the world and certainly the largest
company in the United States is is going
full force producing cadmium telluride
modules the debate question that you'll
be faced with is is it a good investment
for the United States say for example
you're in charge of US government
research and development funds should
you be putting your money into cad-tel
or should you be putting your money into
something else and will have two sides
of the debate one that will defend
cad-tel and say you know it's it's it's
a very promising technology we should be
going all-in and the other side that
will be adopting the counter-argument
saying well Cattell has these concerns
perhaps we should be looking elsewhere
to invest and that's the debate number
one cat tell no cat tell for the folks
working on earth abundant materials the
next the second debate will be focused
on that question recently there's been a
lot of interest in developing abundant
alternatives to say cigs because of the
indium content and cat tell because of
the tellurium content and the the
there's been a huge amount of momentum
behind it but there are a few naysayers
out there who say well wait a second
we've always come up against shortages
of one kind or another since the days of
Malthusian
warning about the limits of population
growth because of limited food supply
but then we develop fertilizers and that
will retain that limit
likewise in these resource abundance
issues I'm sure we're going to find some
new way to extract the metals we'll find
a way around it will develop we'll
discover new deposits and so forth you
hear similar arguments in the Peak Oil
debate right and so what I'd like to do
is to set up two teams there as well to
debate this particular question
and we furthermore recognize that
several of these issues that might
appear black and white and reality have
many shades of gray NPV
now this CapTel debate is one of them
we'll hear the second debate and the
next time and anything from should we
invest in silicon technology or should
we develop thin films will have these
shades of grey as well so it's important
you recognize that simple fact as you
gain maturity and shades of grey in your
own ability to argument one side or
another so thank you and we'll see us on
Thursday
you